واشنطن تتهم طهران بمواصله العنف ضد
المحتجين رغم الغاء شرطه في الاخلاق
ورائبه جمهوريه تصف المتظاهرين بالشجع
مسؤول الاوكراني يؤكدوا ان مسيرات ضربت
قاعدتين روتين يتحدث عن اسقاطي معظم
الصواريخ الروسي
تقرير الامم يكشف عن استخدامه داعش لاسلحه
على اجزاء من العراق
[موسيقى]
اسعد الله صباحكم بكل خير اهلا بكم الى
نشره الى اهم الانباء من العربيه
الجمهوريه في مجلس النواب الامريكي
على موقع تويتر وقوفها الى جانب الشعب
الايراني الذي وصفته بالشجاع وقالت انه
يعاني في ظل نظام استبداديه
ايام رجب
قال لنا ناشطون ايرانيون ودول غربيه من
اهميه تصريح الايرانيه عن الغاء جهاز ما
يسمى شرطه الاخلاق وقالت الخارجيه
الامريكيه انها لم ترصد ما يدل على ان
النظام الايراني حسن من طريق طريقه
معاملته للنساء والفتيات او اوقف العنف
الذي يمارسه ضد المتظاهرين
بشجاعه المحتاجين بدور هذا كره الخارجيه
الالمانيه ان المتظاهرين الايرانيين
يريدون العيش بحريه واستقلاليه وان الغاء
شرطه الاخلاق لن يغير هذا الامر اطلاقا
وقالت مؤسسه الحقوق الانسان والحقوق
الانسان ومقاره الولايات المتحده ان الغاء
وحدات شرطه الاخلاق سيشكل خطوه ضائيه
ومتاخره جدا بالنسبه للمحتاجين
الذين بعثوا يطالبون بتغيير النظام
هذا هو تواصلت تظاهرات في عدد من المدن
الايرانيه لاسيه بالعاصمه طهران ومحافظه
خراسان وفارس ومشهد شمال شرق ايران
المتظاهرون
بممارسه النظام الايرانيه على الرغم من
اعلان انتهاء مهمه ما يطلق عليها شرطه
الاخلاق بامر من النيابه العامه
[تصفيق]
الو الو
كرانيا نقلت صحيفه نيويورك
عسكريتين على بعض مئات داخل روسيا
باستخدام طائرات مسيره وقالت الصحيفه التي
تلك الطائرات انطلقت من اراضي اوكرانيه
فدمر الطائرتين على الاقل في احدى
القاعدتين
طائرات اخرى
وكاله وزاره الدفاع الروسيه على نتاع
اعتراضها دفاعاتها الجويه لعدد من
الطائرات المسيرات اطلقت القوات
الاوكرانيه ضد مطارين في مقاطعه ريازان
وسيراتوف الروسيتين
ديسمبر
الطائره بدون طيار الاوكرانيه التي كانت
تحلق على ارتفاع المنخفض تم اعتراضها من
قبل الدفاع الجوي الروسي
كافيه كثير كثير
اسقطت معظم الصواريخ التي اطلقها الجيش
الروسي يوم امس الامر الذي سمح لمهندسين
الطاقه
الكهربائيه في المناطق التي تضررت بفعل
الضربات الروسيه
وعمال الطاقه لدينا وشعبنا لقد اسقط
الدفاع الجوي معظم الصواريخ الروسيه
الطاقه شعبنا لا يستسلم ابدا
حضر المدعي العام للمحكمه الجنائيه
الدوليه كريم خان من ان تشكيله محكمه خاصه
لمحاسبه موسكو على ارتكاب جرائم مزعومه في
اوكرانيا
الى تركيز جهوده بدلا من ذلك على دعم
وتمويل المحكمه الجنائيه التي تحقق حاليا
في جرائم الحرب والجرائم ضد الانسانيه
التي تتهم بها روسيا لافتا الى ان
الجنائيه الدوليه تواجهه منذ الان عجزان
في الميزان
ذكرت صحيفه البريطانيه ان ناقلات النفط
بدات تتكدس قباله سواحل تركيا في اليوم
الاول من بدء التطبيقي سقف الاسعار على
الخام عروس
[موسيقى]
وكما تشاهدون على عواجل العربيه الصين
تلغي اشتراط وجود فحص البيبي لفيروس
كورونا عند الدخول الى المطارات الصينيه
العربيه وقبل ذلك وفي اطار تخفيف القيود
فيما يتعلق بكرونا كانت الصين قبل ذلك
اعلنت عدم اشتراط وجود فحص البيبي للدخول
الى المحال التجاريه في الصين
باستخدام تنظيم داعش اسلحه كيميائيه بين
عامين 2014
و2019 في مناطق كان يسيطر عليها التنظيم
في العراق
الى ان تنظيم داعش قام بتصنيعه وانتاج
صواريخ ومدافع كيميائيه
ورؤوس حربيه كيماويه واجهزه متفجره ايضا
يدويه الصنع كيماويه واشاره التقرير الى
وجود ادله تثبت اتخاذ داعش ترتيبات
الماليه ولوجستيه وترتيبات تتعلق
بالمشتريات والروابط مع عناصر القياده كما
اشار التقرير الى فهم اكبر للمواقع التي
يشتبهوا في انها شهدت انشطه لصنع الاسلحه
وينتجها واستخدامها في جميع انحاء العراق
وركز المحقق كونان جهودهم خصوصا على هجوم
تعرضت له مدينه تازه
العراقيه في التابوت وفي الثامن من مارس
2016 وكاله انهم جمعوا كميه كبيره من
الادله بما فاذ ذلك سجلات كشوف مرتبات
ايضا في هذه النشره ولكن بعد قليل
البرازيل تمطر شباك كوريا الجنوبيه
برباعيه والمغرب يواجه اسبانيا اليوم
اهلا بكم من جديد رحبت الخارجيه الفرنسيه
بتوقيع الاتفاق الايطالي بين الاطراف
السودانيه وقالت الخارجيه في بيان لها ان
الاتفاق الايطالي يخرج السودان من ازمه
سياسيه خطيره وانه خطوه كبيره لاعاده
السودان
الكامل لمواقبه الاطراف السودانيه من اجل
ابرام اتفاق سياسي النهائي يؤكد استئناف
الانتقال الديمقراطي الذي بدا في عام 2019
رئيس مجلس زياده الانتقاليه السوداني عبد
الفتاح البرهان قال في لقاء خاص مع
العربيه ان الاتفاق الايطالي الذي تم
توقيعه لن يتجاوز احدا الى ان الجميع في
السودان يسعون لحدوث توافق داخل مختلف
القوى السياسيه والعسكريه
لم يتجاوز احد حتى الان وهو مفتوح ومطروح
للجميع اللحاق به ليس تبع ولكن
قضايا نحن نسعى لحدوث توافق اذا كان داخل
القوى السياسيه او داخل القول سياسيه
والعسكريه همم
لكمال هذا توافق بين هذه المجموعات ونزع
الاستكمال توقيع القوه التي نرى انها
ضروريه ان تكون موجوده في ساحه السياسيه
العربيه شرطه الافغانيه تعلن مقتل خمسه
اشخاص في انفجار سياره في اقليم بلغ شمال
افغانستان
في تعز اليمنيه طرت اسره النازحه الى
العيش في منزل المدمر في حي الخضراء شرقي
المدينه يفتقر لابسط مقومات الحياه هذا
وتعجز الاسر اليمنيه على اوعاني الحصول
على مياه الشرب نظيفه والغذاء جراء القنص
والقصف مستمر
بحذر شديد تكون حركتها في الحي خوفا من
القناص ف السلاح الحوثي ذاته الذي قتل
زوجها قنصل قبل اعوام يتهددها اليوم مع
اطفالها الى الحيه في المنزل المدمر هذا
هو الذي لا يبرد سوى 20 مترا على خط
المواجهه تعيش الام واطفالها حياه قاسيه
تحت هدير المدافع وازيز الرصاص
في منطقه تماسك
مسكون انا وزوجها واولادي الاربعه ثنتين
بنات اثنين عيال ونجحنا لهذا المنطقه اللي
هي كمان منطقه تماس
والرغم من البيت مدمر واحنا عايشين فيها
الى المسجد وحشرتهم في غرفه واحده الام في
حاله الرعب والفقر التي تعيشها الاسره
تنسحب ايضا على عشرات الاسر النازحه الى
هذه المنازل المدمره بعد انفرت من جحيم
الميليشيات
منطقه العمور
هجرب البيت وبيتي كانت مقاول لها راحت بعد
البيت الجديد في الجروب
[موسيقى]
لا سلطان محليه للتضعف اذا ماساه النازحين
في تعز
ومعهاناه في ظل الحصار ففي احياء الزهره
والكلب والخضره شرقي المدينه تعيش اكثر من
170 اسره نازحه في خط تماسي الحرب دون ان
تحصل على ابسط مقومات العيش كالماء
والغداء لاحد اذا يسكن هذه المنازل المدره
عند خطوط تماسي الحرب شرقي مدينه تعز سوى
الاسر الناجحه التي اضطرت الى ذلك بعد ان
عجزت من الحصول على مساكن امنه فهم يعيشون
داخل هذه المنازل دائما تساقط القذائف على
رؤوسهم هل سعيد لقناتيه العربيه والحدث من
حي الخضراء شرقيه مدينه تعز
تسلم ممثله سعوديه دكتور عقيل بن جمعان
الغامدي رئاسه مجموعه الدول المالحه
الداعمه لمكتب تنسيق الشؤون الانسانيه في
الامم المتحده من الرئيس الحالي للمجموعه
ممثله مملكه هولندا مريد شاورمان
افتتاحيه الى حجم الفجوه بين تبرعات الدول
المالحه والاحتياجات الانسانيه المتصاعده
خلال عام 20 23
مليار ونصف الملياردو دولار
جهود لاعداد خطه العمل لرئاسه لمجموعه
وان رؤيتها تمثل او تتمثل في دعم الدوري
التنسيقي الانساني لمكتب الامم المتحده
لتنسيق الشؤون الانساني
موضوع الاحتياجات الانسانيه
والمعوقات والتحديات في النقاشه اليوم كما
تعلم ااا ارتفعت الاحتياجات خلال العام
الحالي والعام القادم ارتفعت من 274 مليون
شخص في حاجه الى 339 مليون شخص في حاجه في
حوالي 68 دوله تقريبا الزياده حوالي 25%
اا قبل عده سنوات كان الاحتياج حوالي 20
او اقل من 20 مليار دولار نحن اليوم نتكلم
على احتياج بحوالي 51 ونصف مليار دولار
الاحتياجات كبيره
ومحاولات وضع اولويات اللي همم الاحتياجات
الانسانيه اهم همم
الاشتياجات في ما تم مناقشته اليوم
مركزيه الكوريه الشماليه
امارات وحدات العسكريه باطلاق المزيد من
قذائف المدفعيه نحو البحر يعقب تدريبات
الجاريه في كوريا الجنوبيه عبر الحدود
وياتي اطلاق النار بعد يوم من اعلان كوريا
الشماليه انها اطلقت اكثر من 130 قذيفه في
البحر قباله سواحلها الشرقيه والغربيه سقط
بعضها في منطقه العازله بالقرب من الحدود
البحريه بين الكوريتين
تواجه شركه نيولايت او اللينك للاجهزه
الطبيه التابعه لاير ماسك تحقيق الاتحاديا
في مزاعب عن انتهاكات المحتمله لحقوق
الحيوان وسطا شكاوى من موظفين بشركه من
تسريع التجارب على الحيوانات ما تسبب في
نفوق الكثير منها دون داعا وفاد مصدران
مطلعان لوكاله رويترز العربي وزاره
الزراعه الى ملكيه بدات تحقيق بناء على
طلب اتحادي وقال احد المسطرين ان التحقيق
يركز على انتهاكات قانون رعايه الحيوانات
التي او الذي يحكم كيفيه معامله الباحثين
للحيوانات
في ختام هذه النشره تذكير بابراز العالمون
واشنطن تنتهي مطهران بمواصله العنف ضد
المحتجين رغم الغاء شرطه الاخلاق ونائبه
جمهوريه تصف المتظاهرين بالشجاعه
رسول الله
نهيت هذه النشرات دايما للمزيد على
العربيه دوت نت شكرا لمتابعتكم والى
اللقاء
[موسيقى]